Die Hypothese des britischen Biologen Rupert
Sheldrake klingt wirklich ziemlich crazy:
Demnach wird nämlich alles, was irgendwo
entsteht, in Form eines übersinnlichen Codes
abgespeichert - und zwar im sogenannten “morphischen
Feld”.
Dadurch können andere Entstehungsprozesse
anderswo viel einfacher ablaufen.
Ein Beispiel dafür: Der erste Entstehungsprozess
eines neuartigen Kristalls dauert sehr lange.
Eine weitere Kristallisation gelingt dann
aber deutlich schneller, weil die Atome wissen,
wie sie sich anzuordnen haben.
Eine Art kosmisches WLAN also.
Was ist da dran?
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, - abonniert den
Kanal, denn nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Und danke für Euren Themenvorschlag über
unser coole Telegram Community.
Die Hypothese über die sogenannten “Morphischen
Felder” kommt von dem Briten Rupert Sheldrake,
der in Cambridge Biologie und an der Harvard-University
Philosophie studiert hat.
Seinen Überlegungen aus dem Jahr 1981 zufolge
ist der Kosmos von sogenannten morphischen
Feldern durchzogen.
Und diese sind demnach nicht ohne, denn sie
haben maßgeblichen Einfluss auf die Entwicklung
von Strukturen.
Sheldrake bezeichnet sie auch als das “Gedächtnis
der Natur”.
Der Biologe befasst sich mit der Entwicklung
von Pflanzen und forschte zum Thema Zellalterung.
Genau dadurch kam Sheldrake auf seine Hypothese
zu den morphischen Feldern: “Mein Interesse
an diesen Ideen erwachte während meiner Forschungstätigkeit
zur Evolution von Pflanzen an der Universität
Cambridge.
Wie entwickeln sich Pflanzen aus einfachen
Embryonen zur charakteristischen Form ihrer
Art?
Wie nehmen die Blätter von Weiden, Rosen
und Palmen ihre Form an?
Wie entwickeln ihre Blüten sich auf so unterschiedliche
Weise?
All diese Fragen haben etwas mit dem zu tun,
was die Biologen Morphogenese nennen, die
Entstehung von Form (...), die eines der großen
ungelösten Probleme der Biologie ist.”
Sheldrakes Grundidee in einem Satz zusammengefasst:
Alles, was neu entsteht, wird in einer Art
übersinnlichem Code gespeichert und zwar
in einem sogenannten “morphischen Feld”.
Nehmen wir das Beispiel einer Ratte, die verzweifelt
einen Weg aus dem Labyrinth heraus sucht.
Nach langer verzweifelter Suche hat das Tier
dann Erfolg.
Ihre Lösung wird Sheldrakes Idee zufolge
in einem morphischen Feld gespeichert und
andere Ratten haben es danach sehr viel einfacher,
den Weg aus dem Labyrinth zu finden.
Nach Sheldrake kann das Ganze auch auf andere
Bereiche übertragen werden - beispielsweise
auf die Chemie.
Die erstmalige Entstehung eines neuen Kristalls
dauert ziemlich lange.
Doch das morphische Feld speichert die Anordnung
der Atome, sodass eine weitere Kristallisation
sehr viel einfacher gelingt.
Aber auch wir Menschen können Sheldrake zufolge
auf das im morphischen Feld gespeicherte Wissen
zugreifen.
Denn wie sonst kann es sein, dass Albert Einstein
jahrelang dafür brachte, um seine Relativitätstheorie
aufzustellen - ein gewöhnlicher Physikstudent
es aber heutzutage schafft, sich diese Inhalte
in wenigen Monaten in seinen Kopf zu laden?
Klar ist: Rupert Sheldrake gilt im Esoterik-Bereich
als ein ganz großer Kopf.
In der seriösen Wissenschaft dagegen nicht,
denn seine Hypothese zu den morphischen Felder
konnte nie bewiesen werden.
Auch Sheldrake selbst gelingt das nicht.
Dafür müsste er zwei oder drei einfache
Experimente so exakt auszuführen, das als
einzige mögliche Erklärung die morphischen
Felder bleiben.
Sheldrake versucht es durch einen deutlich
weniger wissenschaftlichen Weg, Menschen von
seiner Idee zu überzeugen.
Immer wieder tischt er neue angeblich morphische
Phänomen, sodass wissenschaftliche Experimente
kaum hinterherkommen, Sheldrakes Behauptungen
zu widerlegen.
Doch warum genau sollte es an morphischen
Feldern liegen, dass Einsteins Relativitätstheorie
heute mit Hilfe durchdachter Vorlesungs-Skripte
einfacher zu verstehen sind?
Liegt es nicht viel näher, dass es für Einstein
selbst eine solch komplizierte Sache war,
weil er seine Formeln erarbeiten und überhaupt
erstmalig aufzustellen musste!?
Chemische Reaktionen laufen nicht aufgrund
morphischer Felder in heutigen Laboren schneller
und unkomplizierter ab als früher.
Stattdessen ist der Reinheitsgrad der Chemikalien
einfach deutlich besser; zudem steht uns deutlich
mehr Wissen zur Verfügung als noch vor einigen
Jahren.
Sheldrakes Experimente mit den Ratten konnten
in anderen Studien nicht wiederholt werden
und auch andere Experimente mit Tieren konnten
die Theorie des morphischen Feldes nicht untermauern.
Und das gilt auch, obwohl man in manchen Situationen
tatsächlich den Eindruck gewinnen könnte,
dass ab und an eine Art “außersinnliche
Gedankenübertragung” stattfindet.
Manchmal liegt einfach eine Idee in der Luft,
die noch einige Zeit zuvor undenkbar gewesen
ist.
Nicht abzustreiten, dass wir anders denken
als unsere Vorfahren in der Steinzeit: Wir
schreiben E Mails, obwohl man dies erst vor
einigen Jahren noch in Experten-Kursen lernen
musste.
Wir feiern die Demokratie als die einzig wahre
und korrekte Staatsform und wir alle wissen,
dass Frauen und Männer gleich viel wert sind.
Doch all diese Selbstverständlichkeiten sind
noch gar nicht lange selbstverständlich.
Doch das alles ist keineswegs ein Beweis für
die Existenz der morphischen Feldern.
Im Gegenteil: Das Ganze liegt wohl einfach
darin begründet, dass unser Denken ganz stark
von unserem Umfeld; also von der Gesellschaft,
in der wir leben, beeinflusst wird.
Unsere Gedanken und Ideen entstehen eben nicht
isoliert in unserem Kopf, sondern sind das
Ergebnis eines komplexes Wechselspiels.
Also Morphische Felder gibt es nicht, wohlaber
hat die Mondlandung stattgefunden!
Am 20.
Juli berichten wir zwölf Stunden lang “live”
von der Mondlandung vor 50 Jahren.
Sekundengenau mit all dem Wissen, das wir
heute haben.
Mit dabei: die Astronauten Gerhard Thiele
und Reinhold Ewald, die wir vorab sehr lange
zur Raumfahrt ausgequetscht haben und zahlreiche
Wissenschaftsyoutuber, wie Astro Comics TV,
Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft, Breaking Lab, Der
Medizinstudent, Doktor Whatson und Neugierzone.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt, dann klickt
hier und merkt euch den Stream vor.
Um 21 Uhr am Samstag, den 20.
Juli geht es los.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!